today for our daily cancellation i'll be
canceling all the people freaking out
over the chiefs fans
last night uh booing the players as they
had their moment of unity
so backing up here for a moment the nfl
was back in action on thursday night
not a very interesting game chiefs won
34 to 20. of course the question was
what would happen before the game you
know how far would the nfl go in the
first game back to alienate the fan base
even further
i thought at the very least they might
randomly select a white fan from the
stands and drag them onto the field to
be ritualistically flogged as atonement
for the myriad sins of whiteness
but shockingly that didn't happen there
was none of that there there wasn't much
of anything the texans didn't come out
for the anthem at all which
fine i prefer that i prefer that over
the theatrics during the anthem
just get it out of sight as far as i'm
concerned uh the chiefs all
all stood but one player so that wasn't
too bad
but then right before the game started
they went out
onto the field locked arms and had a
moment of unity
and the fans didn't seem to like it very
much listen
thank you
[Music]
now the left and the and the people in
sports media but i repeat myself i
suppose
have been fainting quite performatively
over this
they booed a moment of unity why i never
um that's how i imagine them when
they're tweeting
doing this with their hands how dare
these you know how dare these fans boo
racial unity they must be a bunch of
racists how could they a headline on the
the leftist news site raw story called
the fans classless trash
john fuglesang said america's racists
always booing at demonstrations against
the racism
never booing at actual racism sports
writer michael lee was
uh was was very upset he said my
hometown's got no love for unity they're
booing unity now
charlotte climber of the extremist group
the human rights campaign said
who's surprised by these fans who are
booing it was never about the national
anthem
it was never about respect for the flag
it was always about sheer discomfort
over any personal accountability a fan
might be motivated to consider
regarding their role in systemic racism
another media person
cameron justice said booing equality is
pretty telling
and on and on and on now all of this of
course misses the point on purpose
despite the pretensions of the left
nobody is against
unity or justice or equality
the left likes to pretend that it's
waging a war against cartoon villains
who are
in principle actually opposed to you
know things like justice as if we're
saying
yeah you know we're not big fans of
justice just uh it doesn't do much for
us we're
we're sort of anti-justice we're big
fans of injustice actually where
injustice that's more our speed now
that's not a position that anybody holds
even people who actually do favor
injustice like the people who defend
rioters and looters as they burn down
city blocks
those are people who favor injustice but
they don't see themselves that way they
would never
be that explicit about it in fact they
feel the need to claim
that rioting and looting is justice and
to defend it on that basis
that's how humans work it's called
rationalizing
so why were people booing
well the reason people booed the moment
of unity is that
we have come to understand what is
really meant in our culture
by unity it's just like when someone
starts talking about being anti-racist
i'd be that too is that because i'm
pro-racist
no it's because when i hear someone talk
about being anti-racist
i know that they don't really mean
anti-racist i know that anti-racism is a
euphemism
and a lot of a lot of actual racism is
promoted and justified under the guise
of being
anti-racist so yes i boo you when you
say it because
i know what you really mean and you know
what you really mean
so let's stop pretending we don't
understand each other
this is the way the game is always
played though with the left they do the
same thing with black lives matter
if somebody opposes black lives matter
they say oh you don't think black lives
matter huh no
i do think black lives matter everybody
thinks that nearly everyone in the
country agrees on that point
near unanimous agreement but you keep
saying it anyway why is that because
behind that slogan is a whole bunch of
other stuff
that has nothing to do with with black
people at all and all i need to do is
check out the black lives matter website
look at their professional beliefs
uh their their agenda as they lay it out
themselves
to confirm that this has nothing to do
with black people at all
and there are dozens of examples of this
pro-choice oh you don't believe in
choice do you no i do
i think freedom of choice is good but i
also think that killing innocent people
is bad and when you talk about choice i
know
that's what you actually mean and so
that's why i boo
your pro-choice slogans because i know
that they are really pro-murder
so going back to the racial unity bit i
believe in racial unity
i would love to have racial unions i
would love to have all kinds of unity in
this country
but is that really what you want on the
left is that what you mean
when you talk about it do you mean that
we will all be unified on an equal
playing field and that will we will live
our lives and treat each other as human
beings without segregation without any
need for anyone to apologize for their
race or
to profess feelings of guilt or to take
a submissive or groveling stance
that the law will treat everyone the
same and everybody's held to the same
standard and so on
is that what you mean it isn't is it
well then you don't really want racial
unity you want something else
and it's that something else that was
booed
and deserves to be booed now personally
the players locking arms and and
standing there doesn't bother me any
doesn't offend me
if i was in the stands i probably
wouldn't boot it and i i can
as far as the nfl players themselves go
i could i could very well believe that
that many of them if not most of them
really had
great intentions and and as far as
they're concerned they really were
standing for unity it was kind of an
empty gesture but whatever
uh basically harmless yet
um the the fans in the stands
and so many other people they are jaded
and cynical when it comes to these kinds
of gestures and statements
and for highly justified reasons
because they see how in our culture the
left takes
these concepts and ideas that
by definition in reality are good
the left takes them empties them out
turns them into
euphemisms that stand for things that
have nothing really to do with those
words at all
and that's what the booing was about um
so and that's why if you're complaining
about the booing you're canceled
okay hey you uh yeah you
you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now do it do it
right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated